[CLOCK TICKING]
[SNAP]
[SQUIRT]
That's the foot.
Any pain?
What's wrong?
[SNAP]
[SQUIRT]
That's the foot.
Feels like, we should be,
happier.
Any pain?
I want Schmigadoon.
Happy people and bright colors.
♪♪
Schmigadoon where are you!?
Maybe it's one of those places that
you only go once and never return.
Oh, like Soul Cycle.
Schmicago?
♪♪
♪ Welcome to Schmicago ♪
This is very different.
Now our heroes enter the city of Schmicago!
Who is he talking to?
Oh, at one point, a lot of musicals had narrators.
Sorry, go ahead.
Really?
Do I have your permission?
Uh oh. He's peppery.
♪♪
Clearly, we're in the next era of musicals here.
♪ Do we shock you ♪
These musicals are darker.
Aah!
Heh Heh [snorts]
With more sex.
Ooh yay.
And violence.
[GUNFIRE]
Murder!
Oh you gotta be kidding me.
♪♪
How are we supposed to make a happy ending here!?
These musicals don't have happy endings.
♪♪
Sounds like someone needs a lesson
in the power of happiness.
Who wants to get naked?
♪♪
What I need is a lawyer.
Once I've worked my magic
no jury will ever convict your hubby
even if he kills again!
Josh didn't do it.
Uh huh.
♪♪
♪ Mystery and Magic ♪
♪ Endings that are tragic ♪
♪ Welcome to ♪
♪♪
♪ Schmicago ♪
Sounds like another wild night in Schmicago.
So, you two want a girl?
♪♪
You need my help... to answer that question?
No thank you.